how did Dua LIPA get discovered a bit of  a long story but I'll try and like  shorten it a little bit when I was young  you know I always wanted to make music I  started making YouTube covers and I  started showing them to my friends in  school and then I used them as like a  form of portfolio to like work with  different producers and get in the  studio and I was like you know I sing  and I would love it if I would get in  the studio and write together I made a  bunch of demos and then I basically  Googled managers in London and then I  got offered like a publishing deal then  I had to find a lawyer and then the  lawyer was trying to like help me and  was like don't sign this publishing deal  whatever you do let me help you find a  manager and he introduced me to my  manager Ben and so that was a really  really long story  cut short  [Music]